serena williams and alexis ohanian are
married the tennis pro and the reddit
co-founder tied the knot on Thursday
just 11 weeks after welcoming their baby
girl Alexis olimpio Hanny and junior
into the world the two said I do at the
Contemporary Art Center in New Orleans
in front of a slew of celebrity guests
including Beyonce Eva Longoria and her
husband Jose bastogne Sierra La La
Anthony Kelly Rowland and Colton Haynes
who got emotional talking about the
evening on Instagram crying because one
of my best friends got married and it
was so beautiful it was amazing Kim
Kardashian was also in attendance and
stopped for her favorite big easy treat
on the way home okay you know I wouldn't
come to New Orleans out getting beignets
from Cafe Du Monde or six bags at the
yeas a source tells ET that the Beauty
and the Beast themed wedding was quote
magical adding the reception was
beautiful
the crowd was roaring everyone had a
blast
including the bride who rocked a pair of
custom Nike sneakers at the reception
the happy couple began dating in 2015
and announced their engagement in
December 2016
Ohan Ian first hinted at their
connection at the 2015 US Open when he
shared this pic with the caption come at
the Queen you best not miss
[Music]
you